justice stephen breyer heads for the
exits before the midterm elections joe
biden considers which black woman to
pick and the federal reserve announces
it will raise interest rates soon i'm
bench bureau this is the bench bureau
[Music]
show today's show is sponsored by
expressivevpn do you like your web
history being seen and sold to
advertisers no me neither get expressvpn
right now at expressvpn.com
ben speaking of which what if there was
someone out there who every day was just
keeping a log of what you did whether
you'd been naughty or nice i'm not
talking about santa claus or god i'm
talking about big tech those overlords
they're keeping a log of everything you
do your isp is allowed to store logs of
every website you've ever visited and
can legally sell that data to anyone
which is why i always use expressvpn
expressvpn reroutes your internet
connection through their secure servers
so your internet provider cannot see or
log what you do online now many of you
might be wondering if i'm routing all my
data through a vpn doesn't that mean
that the vpn can actually gather all of
that data well you're right to think
that because some vpns actually do that
some of those free vpns that you get
well expressvpn does not i trust them
because they use trusted server
technology they were the first major vpn
provider to engineer all of their vpn
servers to run in ram which makes it
impossible for their vpn servers to
store any data including logs of any
expressvpn customer and you don't have
to take my word for it expressvpn is so
confident in their no logs claim they
even had one of the biggest assurance
firms price waters has cooper audit
their technology stop letting people
keep logs of what you do online visit
expressvpn.com right now find out how
you can get three months for free that's
expr essvpn.combenexpressvpn.com
ben to learn more alrighty so yesterday
justice stephen breyer announced that he
would be leaving the supreme court at
the end of the current term but he
really didn't announce it it was just
sort of announced for him and apparently
he was kind of ticked about all of this
there were multiple reports yesterday
that he had planned on announcing this
but it sort of leaked before he was
ready for it according to shannon breme
according to breitbart.com many reports
indicated the breyer was surprised and
caught off guard about the announcement
neither briar nor the supreme court has
issued a public announcement about his
supposed retirement the white house and
president biden have refused to comment
on the news which was first reported by
cnbc
biden said there's been no announcement
from justice prior let him make whatever
statement he's going to make i'll be
happy to talk about it later
upon rumors biden may nominate vice
president kamala harris to the white to
the supreme court white house press
secretary jen saki said she would not
comment on any potential nominees here
was jen saki yesterday saying that she
wouldn't answer if kamala harris might
be
continuing her her giant ride upward
based on failure i've never seen someone
fail up as much as kamala harris and
she's a failed attorney general she
failed upward into the senate she failed
upward from the senate into the vice
presidency and now there's talk she may
fail upward from the vice presidency
into the supreme court just so they can
get rid of her like she's so bad at vp
when the democrats cannot have her as
the nominee should joe biden go down
they're like let's just
stick that lady over at the supreme
court she'll be a reliable vote for
anything that we need and sure she sucks
at everything but who cares about that
here is jen saki refusing to answer the
question yesterday
when you were asked about the vice
president possibly being selected as a
supreme court nominee you said you're
not going to speak to any considerations
does that mean she is being considered
again peter i'm not going to speak to
the reports of a supreme court justice
retirement that hasn't been announced so
theoretically would someone who
theoretically i do like that you preface
it i appreciate it just wondering
hypothetically theoretically uh would
someone who was
an attorney general of a large state and
who served with many key senate votes be
an attractive candidate to the president
for an open supreme court seat i see
what you did there peter but the
president has every intention as he said
before of running free of reelection and
for running for reelection with uh vice
president harris on the ticket as his
partner
okay so of course that's probably right
they're not going to nominate kamal
harris there are a few complicating
factors first of all kamal harris is the
tie-breaking vote she would have to
presumably resign from her seat as vice
president of the united states in order
to be considered for the supreme court
he'd have to select a new vice president
and at that point that person would be
the tiebreaker because she'd have to not
vote on her own nomination so that's
really kind of ridiculous and insane so
so kamal harris is not going to be the
nominee it is hilarious that the left
was so nervous about the 2022 elections
that they basically just bodily threw
stephen breyer off the supreme court so
you remember that ruth bader ginsburg
the notorious rbg heroine to the masses
the the person that the left worshipped
i mean they made documentaries about her
and they had voted candles of her and
she was the most important justice on
the supreme court despite the fact that
she really wasn't all that important to
justice in the grand scheme of things
from very few
extraordinarily
important decisions over her tenure at
the supreme court she was just a
reliable vote for the left
justice ruth bader ginsburg made the
crucial error of thinking that hillary
clinton was going to win the 2016
election and so she didn't step down
despite some pressure to do so and then
donald trump won and then ruth bader
ginsburg seat was filled by donald trump
which meant that the court shifted from
basically even to now a 6-3 supreme
court because donald trump got three
picks while he was president of the
united states and
at least two of them were swings right
one was one was ginsburg seat and one
was the the seat
for uh for justice kennedy so you'll
remember that ruth bader ginsburg died
in september 2020 while trump was
president she thought hillary was going
to be president and hillary wasn't so
that meant that trump got to replace her
democrats want to avoid that this time
democrats also want to avoid the
situation they had when justice scalia
died because justice scalia died well
there was a democratic president but
there was a republican senate and what
they were afraid of here is that breyer
would pass away or would leave while the
republicans controlled the senate and
republicans could just prevent a
democratic pick from taking the seat so
they basically just announced it for him
he's sitting over there in the corner
and he's like yeah i'll probably you
know go whenever and they're like you
shut your face you're leaving now
which is why he's kind of pissed off
according to nbc news president biden
and briar are scheduled to appear
together at the white house on thursday
as the supreme court justice is set to
announce his retirement breyer is one of
the three remaining liberal justices his
decision to retire after more than 27
years on the court allows biden to
appoint a successor who could serve for
decades and in the short term maintain
the current 6-3 split between
conservative and liberal justices now
again this is not a swing seat buyer's
seat being filled by somebody on the
left would just be a left seat being
filled by somebody on the left at 83
breyer is the court's oldest member
liberal activists have urged him for
months to retire while democrats hold
both the white house and the senate and
he's been
pretty
annoyed
by the by the pressure that he's been
getting from the outside
uh apparently that pressure has been
mounting over the course of months
there's an article from september 2021
from a site called ballsandstrikes.org
called bullying stephen breyer is good
actually
we need to throw this old man out of
here get him the hell out of here before
ron desantis or donald trump becomes
president and at that point it's gonna
be very very difficult for us to replace
a liberal with another liberal that's
all they care about now who is joe biden
going to replace stephen breyer with
well we know the answer to this one
because joe biden set it back during the
campaign during the campaign joe biden
kept pledging that every
open position was going to violate
federal civil rights law he was just
going to select a black woman for
everything for his vice president for
the supreme court justice for dog
catcher did not matter it was going to
be a black woman no matter what here was
joe biden during the 2020 campaign
saying that he would pick a black woman
to fill the supreme court see because
again by the way this violates federal
civil rights law there's no other area
of american life where you could say i
want a white male for an ex-seat you
couldn't say it it's literally a
violation of the equal protection clause
of the constitution of the united states
you're not saying as one factor among
many i want a woman who has the
experience of a black woman right first
of all that's a ridiculous assertion on
its face because not all black women
have the same experiences but put that
aside even if you use the
multi-factorial analysis that the
supreme court has been fond of with
regard to affirmative action programs at
universities as we talked about the
other day on the show
even if you threw that aside why didn't
you even say that he just said i want a
black woman okay there is no other area
of american legal jurisprudence where
you could say i want a person of this
specific race and this specific sex to
fill this particular role and that not
be a violation of the equal protection
clause here is joe biden pledging to do
it back in 2020.
i committed that if i'm elected
president have an opportunity to appoint
someone to the courts will be i'll
appoint the first black woman to the
courts it's required that they have
representation now it's long overdue
okay so um that is an insane contention
right off the top right i mean and the
fact that we all sort of accept this as
wrote is wild that that presidents of
the united states can now just say
things like that that they can just go
out there and be like i want a person of
this particular race and this particular
sex and it doesn't matter anything else
but this is the way that the left views
the court by the way the left views the
court as two things one a place to put
people of particular races in particular
sexes and two that person has to
reliably vote for the left
hey this has nothing to do with
qualifications now some of the people
who are being considered for the sea
have the usual qualifications for a
supreme court justice namely an ivy
league school and a clerkship maybe a
few years as a judge right that sort of
stuff is not
is is sort of de regor for the seat but
democrats don't care about that what
they really care about is we must have
black women and not only must she be a
black woman she must vote reliably for
the left see here's the thing democrats
never miss on their picks they never
ever miss on their picks ever and the
reason democrats never miss on their
picks is because they just select people
who are overt leftists the right plays
this game it's this really stupid game
where in their hopes of getting somebody
through the senate confirmation process
they pick somebody who's sort of a
cipher and they pick john roberts who's
been on the dc circuit court of appeals
for a little while
has never written a controversial
decision has never been at the eye of
the hurricane and so tends toward the
pragmatist and and the political and and
they never just pick somebody who is
overtly conservative right you never see
the the conservative movement or the
federalist society or the president of
the united states selecting somebody who
is the lawyer for the national right to
life fund they never do this now ruth
bader ginsburg was the actual lawyer for
the national organization for women
okay democrats do this right thurgood
marshall was the lawyer for the naacp
they will just go to an organization
that is allied with them and then they
will say who is your best lawyer and
then they will pick that person they
will elevate them to the supreme court
they don't make this mistake they find
somebody who has been through the wars
on behalf of the left and then they
select that person for the supreme court
or they just openly ask them things like
will you uphold the roe vs wade and that
person will be like sure you never hear
the right ask somebody will you overturn
roe versus wade which should be a litmus
test the left gets this right and the
right gets this wrong
the left selects justices based on what
they will do
the right should select justices based
on what they will do not on the basis of
political persuasion per se but based on
the reality that the supreme court has
been a political body and has made
political decisions that are wildly
unconstitutional it seems to me a legal
litmus test whether a justice will vote
to overturn roe if you will not vote to
overturn roe you should not be sitting
on the supreme court certainly not as
appointed by a republican president of
the united states roe versus weight is
wildly unconstitutional it's insane roe
vs wade is a ridiculous decision on its
face and any justice who sort of is
unwilling to say that openly should not
be nominated to the supreme court of the
united states by republicans the
republicans are always going for
consensus they're always looking for we
need 60 votes we need seven votes who
cares who cares first of all democrats
don't give you the authority to do that
anyway democrats will never ever again
allow a republican president who
selected justice and that justice gets
through with 70 votes it's not going to
happen anymore every single republican
appointee is going to be selected with
all republican votes and maybe one or
two democratic votes that's it
and so this ridiculous notion by
republicans that when they select
somebody for the supreme court they have
to pick somebody who has wide support
it's ridiculous democrats don't make the
same mistake democrats just assume that
republicans will will admit their people
to the supreme court so long as
democrats have the majority in the
senate many of them will just vote for
it and they'll go along to get along and
then they select people who are overtly
left-wing
democrats when joe biden says he wants a
black woman for the supreme court it
does not matter to democrats whether
that black woman is katanji brown
jackson or whether it is cardi b it does
not make any difference one of those
people has the normal resume
qualifications one of those people
absolutely does not but it does not
matter so long as carde v voted the
white way the right way first of all
they would say that cardi b is a genius
right they would say that if you had
questions about her qualifications this
made you a racist because this is the
game the left loves to play
okay but but in reality they don't care
so long as they get their results
oriented jurisprudence they're done
they're finished now here's the
difference between what the right would
do on this and what the left would do
you could ask a potential right-wing
justice like a clarence thomas type you
could ask
should roe versus wade be overturned and
they say yes and then you say
well what should we do with regard to
for example
the federal civil rights act in 1964 and
its violation of freedom of association
and you might get a bunch of different
answers because there are a bunch of
different answers on the right to these
questions there is no variation on the
left there's lockstep adherent to basic
rules of interpretation on the left and
those rules of interpretation are what
would a normal elected democrat do we
will do that thing
there is no differentiation on the left
between what the supreme court does and
what the legislature does no
differentiation whatsoever
right where the left sits all they care
about is that a supreme court justice
does what they want that justice to do
it does not matter whether that justice
is being asked to wildly exceed their
own authority
so that is why joe biden can say things
like i want a black lady
and that that's that's why they can say
that because what they really mean is
and we all know this they don't mean i
am looking for a person with the black
female experience or a black female to
fulfill the
to rectify discrimination in the past
they mean we want somebody who fulfills
all of our political priors and happens
to please a particular political
constituency
so they can overtly discriminate against
people which is really an amazing shift
by the way it's a it's an amazing tonal
shift in american politics you wouldn't
heard bill clinton doing this in the 90s
you just wouldn't have
and here's the here's the more amazing
thing if joe biden wanted to select a
black woman he doesn't even have to say
it he didn't have to say in 2020 he
could have just selected a black woman
he would have gotten the same credit but
here's the thing if you're a politician
like joe biden you know that in order to
please political constituencies you have
to overtly pledge to be a racist in
advance you have to say in advance i
will select a black woman so that black
people supposedly
this is the way the left thinks about
black voters
that they can be bought with something
like that and if you say that then
you'll win their vote and then you have
to hold to the pledge and this is how
kamal o'hara sends up as vice president
of the united states despite being just
a gas bag of terribleness he'll get some
more on this in just one second first if
somebody relies on your financial
support whether it's a child or an aging
parent even a business partner you need
life insurance let's say that you are
alternatively a random guy in a horror
movie or the girl who gets around in a
horror movie or any of the other horror
movie tropes and you find yourself in a
horror movie right you just find
yourself in an abandoned house somewhere
well at this point you should start
thinking about two things one how the
hell do i get out of here before i'm the
first person killed on screen and two
did i get life insurance from policy
genius if not you have made a grave
error well two grave errors actually
first head on over to policygenius.com
apparel answer a few questions about
yourself in a minute you can work out
how much life insurance coverage you
need and compare personalized quotes to
find your best price you could save 50
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius their licensed
experts will help you understand your
options and apply for a policy the
policy genius team works for you not the
insurance companies you can trust them
to offer unbiased help and advocate for
you at every step until you are covered
policy genius does not add on extra fees
policy genius does not sell your
information to third parties policy
genius has thousands of five star
reviews across google and trustpilot
since 2010 policy genius has helped over
30 million people shop for insurance and
placed 120 billion dollars in coverage
head on over to policygenius.com
get your free life insurance quotes see
how much you could save head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro right now to
get started okay so
with all of this said the people that
joe biden is considering he has a few
people on the table and some of them as
i say are just overtly left wing picks
the the most likely person is this woman
named katanji brown jackson who is 51
years old so she'll be on the court for
the next 40 years she has ivy league
credentials she went to harvard law she
clerked for the she went to the harvard
law review she's an editor there she
clerked for three federal judges
including justice breyer himself from 99
to 2000
if nominated and confirmed according to
the washington post jackson will follow
the same track as brett kavanaugh who
also clerked for the justice he
ultimately replaced and also jackson is
coming directly from the dc circuit
court of appeals which is typically seen
as the sort of theater circuit for the
supreme court of the united states right
the dc circuit is where you get
appointed before they
put you into the supreme court of the
united states
and the other picks that are being
considered one of them is cheryl eiffel
who is the head of the naacp legal
defense fund
again this is something the democrats
will do democrats will actively go to to
constituent groups and then they will be
like who's your best lawyer let's just
put that person on the court imagine if
a conservative president
went to cato institute it's like we need
ilya shapiro just give or imagine if
they just went to daily wire and they
were like we need ben right like this
would never happen on the right because
the right doesn't have the stones for
this but the left absolutely has the
stones for this because for the left
again the supreme court is just another
political branch so they can do whatever
the hell they want that is all they care
about getting what they want is all they
care about
again this is why republicans miss 50 of
the time and so here's the thing if the
left is going to treat the supreme court
like a political body
the right should overtly treat the
supreme court like the political body
that it is that does not mean that they
should treat it exactly the same way
because the supreme when i say that the
supreme court should be treated like a
political body what i mean is that the
left has decided rules of constitutional
interpretation do not apply this means
the right can no longer afford to play
ftse in future judicial picks we cannot
have picks like justice roberts we
cannot have pigs
like brett kavanaugh we cannot have
picks who are ciphers okay you can't
have picks not knowing which way they're
going to go you have to have people who
have gone through the wars who've gone
through the battles and if you have to
pass them through with 51 votes you pass
them through with 50 plus one that's
what democrats are going to do right
here
right now
the real reason by the way the briar
stepped down is of course because
democrats are about to get their asses
kicked in 2022. come november it's not
going to be a democratic senate anymore
just like justice scalia died and then
merrick garland was nominated by barack
obama to fill his seat but mitch
mcconnell held up the seat they're
afraid the same thing could happen here
with stephen breyer so that's why briar
is stepping down before november what
people should really should read this as
is not any sort of shock or any sort of
surprise because it's not they should
read it as stephen breyer isn't an idiot
and so stephen breyer decided i'm
leaving before november which
underscores just how dumb ruth bader
ginsburg was not to step down while
barack obama was president waiting
instead until the age of 87 she died in
2020 and of course her seat was then
filled by donald trump okay so right now
according to the new york times
democrats could confirm a successor to
justice stephen breyer without any
republican support under senate rules
that shields a supreme court nomination
from a filibuster but would have to hold
their bare majority together to do so so
basically they have to rely on kirsten
cinema and joe manchin in order to ram
this through i can't imagine that
kirsten cinema and joe manchin won't go
along with the democrats on this one
because harry reid broke this thing a
long time ago harry reid broke the the
idea that you could filibuster a
judicial nominee
years ago and and that is what has
created the current standard which is
that any sheer majority can just pass
through whomever they want right mitch
mcconnell then used that in order to ram
through a bunch of trump's judicial
nominees
according to the new york times the
announcement of justice breyer's
imminent retirement on wednesday set off
a sprint by top democrats to prepare for
a coming confirmation fight over biden's
nominee to succeed him it also prompted
a collective sigh of relief from the
party and its progressive allies who had
worried that a senate takeover by
republicans in the coming midterm
elections could block the president from
filling any vacancies
senator chuck schumer of course said
that biden's nominee will receive a
prompt hearing in the senate judiciary
committee and will be considered and
confirmed by the full u.s senate with
all deliberate speed
now
you will recall that democrats made
precisely the opposite point in 2020
right in 2020 they said after ruth bader
ginsburg died how dare republicans speed
through a nomination we must wait for an
election there must be an election we
have to have a new president before the
rbg seat is filled mitch mcconnell is
like well i still got time on the
calendar so we're going for this thing
same thing right here so democrats
if you held any consistent standard
which of course you don't you would wait
until the midterms i'm not expecting you
to wait until the midterms because i
think mcconnell did the right thing when
you have the majority you ram it through
democrats have the power to ram it
through they will ram it through okay
but just pointing out the wild
inconsistency from the left right here
because the left inconsistency here is
truly amazing right just a few months
ago this is not that long ago end of
2020 ruth bader ginsburg dies we have
about eight weeks until the election
and democrats say we must wait until the
election so that people can speak on who
they want to fill ruth bader ginsburg c
and mcconnell is like no we're doing it
and we'll now democrat she's on the
other foot democrats are doing the same
thing because as always when it comes to
politics for democrats it's just a power
game there is no principle whatsoever
like none
democrats quickly called on biden to
follow through on his promise to
nominate the first black woman to the
court senator patty murray of washington
the number three democrats said i trust
president biden to move forward an
exceptional nominee who uphold all
americans rights and liberties including
protecting voting rights and
reproductive rights see they don't even
bother with the with the legal jargon
here they're just like yeah we need
abortion and uh and we want the voting
rights act back in place so whoever you
can nominate to do those things would be
great i'm ready to move as quickly as
possible she says to consider and
confirm a highly qualified nominee who
will break barriers and make history as
the first black woman on the supreme
court like overt racism overt racism is
totally fine according to the left and
that really is the astonishing thing
we'll get to more of that in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that you're spending too much money on
gas with the crunch in inflation with
the fact that we have supply chain
issues this means the price of gas is
just too high right now well here's the
thing you could be saving 50 cents per
gallon on your first tank of gas and 25
cents per gallon on every gallon after
that if you head on over to get upside
all you have to do is go to the app
store or google play right now and you
download that free get upside app and
then you use promo code shapiro to get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up that's up to 50 cents cash back
don't pay full price at the pump anymore
get cash back using get upside just
download the app for free use promo code
shapiro to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your very first tank of gas
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred dollars
a year in cash back there's no cash the
cash back gets added directly to your
account you can cash out anytime your
bank account paypal or an e-gift card
for amazon and other brands just
download that free get upside app use
promo code shapiro to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cash back on your very first
tank of gas that is promo code shapiro
get that free get upside app use promo
code shapiro get up to 50 cents per
gallon cash back on your very first tank
of gas so i'd be remiss if i did not
play some of the media reactions here of
course the media reactions are all about
we need a black lady that's what we need
now i noticed they're not talking about
any of the conservative black women that
are out there right then those names
will never come up but
what they really mean is we need a
person who checks all of our political
boxes and also is a black person who is
female so therefore you have for example
cnn's laura coates who says i'd be
overjoyed to have somebody who looks
like me on the court she doesn't really
mean that what she really means is i'd
have i'd be overjoyed to see somebody
who looks like me and thinks like me on
the court right because it's not
sufficient to look like you
first of all i think it's an absurdity
that we even talk like this generally in
american politics it's never occurred to
me that i need somebody who looks like
me on the court i need somebody with a
yamaka on the court why would i care if
there's somebody with a yamaka on the
court i'm perfectly happy with somebody
who does the job not according to the
left however because they have ditched
martin luther king long ago for early
malcolm x and here's laura codes
i would be overjoyed and thrilled to
know that somebody who looks like me and
has the mental prowess that each of
these women have and the credibility the
capability the
distinction of having served as judges
and as extraordinary lawyers over their
time would finally and i emphasize the
word finally finally be given the
opportunity to sit on the highest court
in the land
well that i mean that's the important
thing is that you have somebody who
looks like you what are we children here
a nation of children everybody has to
look like you in order for them to be
considered a good supreme court pick
my favorite is uh is is how we have now
decided to group together all of the
other justices right the ideological
diversity matters not for these people
so earl warren is the exact same thing
as byron white who's the exact same
thing as justice scalia according to the
left they're all white men right eli
missed all over at msnbc he's like 108
of 115 justices have been white men yes
and they had a wide variety of
dispositions towards the law as you may
have noticed i care what charac i really
care what goes on more in the gray
matter than in the melanin level of the
skin also i do like how you lump
together all of the jewish justices who
are considered minority justices when
they are appointed at the lewis brandeis
of the world but none of that matters
according according to left okay
meanwhile bad news for the biden
administration because there's no good
news on the economic front for the biden
administration the fed has signaled that
it is about to wildly increase the
interest rates over the course of the
year
according to the wall street journal the
federal reserve signaled to begin
steadily raising interest rates in
mid-march its latest step toward
removing stimulus to bring down
inflation fed chairman jerome pell said
on wednesday the central bank was ready
to raise rates at its march 15th to 16th
meeting and could continue to lift them
faster than it did during the past
decade he said at a news conference
quote this is going to be a urine which
moves steadily away from the very highly
accommodative monetary policy we put in
place to deal with the economic effect
of the pandemic here was jerome powell
announcing all of this
supply yesterday
demand imbalances related to the
pandemic and the reopening of the
economy have continued to contribute to
elevated levels of inflation
in particular bottlenecks and supply
constraints are limiting how quickly
production can respond to higher demand
in the near term
these problems have been larger and
longer lasting than anticipated
exacerbated by waves of the virus
well that means that they're about to
radically
ramp up the tapering and they're about
to radically ramp down the inflation
what that means for joe biden is
probably a slight spike in
unemployment it also means less
investment just because there's less
cash floating around so you're going to
see some stock market dips that's
exactly what happened immediately stocks
sold off well jerome powell was speaking
reversing big gains from earlier in the
day by the way you know there are
certain areas of american life to many
areas of american life where we are just
too reliant on quote unquote experts
administrative experts to run things and
when it comes to our daily lives we are
now reliant on nine justices in supreme
court robes right people in black robes
telling us what to do so we have to
determine whether we get to keep
employing our employees based on whether
justice stephen breyer has a battle
movement that day right that is not good
stuff we should not be relying on the
supreme court of the united states to
determine our liberties and our freedoms
and the founders actually never
conceived of that sort of thing that the
supreme court was going to be the
ultimate guardian of all freedoms and
that everybody else would advocate the
responsibility on this level so you'd
have unelected justices determining our
freedoms and then the administrative
states does the same thing right we have
entire administrative bureaucracies that
are specifically designed to control all
aspects of your life thousands of pages
of regulations every single year tens of
thousands of pages written by faceless
nameless bureaucrats with essentially
lifetime appointments so it's nearly
impossible to fire
and then you have the federal reserve
and we all react in the stock market
based on what jerome powell decides to
do today whether his finger is in the
wind that day this is not how economies
should work
and this is why the idea of a gold
standard was a good thing because it
took out of the control of the federal
government the monetary supply
we should not have the government
determining whether we have inflation or
not we should not have the government
determining
whether the taxpayer is going to be
buying assets from the market at large
okay this sort of thing is absurd on its
face the fact that this is how the stock
market reacts you sit around waiting for
jerome powell to make an announcement
and then you trade stocks based on it
it's really it's really unpleasant when
i say unpleasant i mean that it is it is
corrupt it is corrupting it is it is
ugly it is not a it is not
relying on the diffuse knowledge of the
market is relying on centralized
bureaucrats to figure out what is best
for you
it is it is the death panels of american
politics and these exist all over the
place
it is faceless and aimless bureaucrats
you've never heard of who are
determining every aspect of your life
from the financial to your rights to how
you get to flush your toilet
it's really bad and jerome powell is one
of those people the federal reserve was
never meant to have this sort of power
the federal reserve was meant to be a
backstop in case of runs on banks it was
not meant to be able to control
unemployment
and inflationary policy as a general
rule this has become what the federal
reserve does right it's supposed to
control unemployment
anytime like that's that in and of
itself is crazy whenever you have a
centralized bureaucracy that is
attempting to control unemployment
why that is not how the economy is
supposed to work and it what it really
is is a mask for failures of the
underlying economy is the case that
david bonson has been making the
investment guru right what he's been
saying is we're all worried about
inflation out here and we should be
because inflation is a bad thing but
inflation is not the chief threat to the
american economy the chief threat to the
american economy is lack of real growth
lack of real innovation
regulatory disincentives tax
disincentives the federal reserve
deciding whether or not people invest in
your business based on how much money
they blow into the economy or take out
of the economy right these headwinds are
faced by actual business people every
single day and when the government gets
control of every aspect of the economy
this way then what you are left with
is a bunch of people attempting to read
tea leaves and then trade your stocks
based on them the stocks sold off while
jerome powell was speaking reversing big
gains from earlier in the day the s p
500 closed down 0.1 percent the dow
jones industrial average finished down
0.4 percent the nasdaq inched up
slightly yields on 10-year treasury
securities climbed as investors
anticipated a more aggressive path of
rate rises
pell left open the door to raising
interest rates and consecutive policy
meetings which are held roughly every
six weeks the fed hasn't done that since
2006. he said i don't think it's
possible to say exactly how this is
going to go i think there's quite a bit
of room to raise interest rates without
threatening the labor market
pel's remarks led investors and interest
rate futures markets to fully anticipate
a march rate increase of at least one
quarter percentage point and nearly 70
percent chance of a second rate
increased by the fed's meeting after
that in early may
pell suggested the fed wasn't likely to
offer any forward guidance the term used
for the central banks statements
describing its intentions with interest
rates over the next few years forward
guidance has been a central feature of
fed policy so now they're not even going
to give you any sort of guide post for
the next several years so if you're an
investor one of the things that you
search for is a solid investment that is
going to give you return for the next
several years and in order to know that
you have to know what the fed is going
to do now the fight is like well we
could change on a dime
maybe we could be fast moving i mean
boom fast acting tinactin of the
financial financial markets well that
that is not a good thing
there is a an author named george gilder
who writes on economics all the time
when he has described the idea of what
he calls information theory the basic
idea is this when you are investing
you should think of investing as adding
new information to a phone line if
there's a lot of static on the phone
line the new information may not get
through
so the goal of the financial regulators
should be to have a static free phone
line in other words the conditions don't
change on the ground very fast you have
a lot of notice if the conditions are
going to change and that way you don't
have a lot of sort of garbled
interference from the top levels and yet
now the federal reserve is overtly
announcing there's going to be a lot of
garbled nonsense from the top levels
you're going to get staticy interference
on that line on a regular basis now
in 2015 according to the wall street
journal the fed prepared markets for a
mild path of no more than one rate rise
every quarter by saying increases would
be only gradual press twice wednesday on
whether the fed would follow that
approach powell points it to how the
economy is much different now with high
inflation in very tight labor markets
the takeaway said christina hooper chief
global market strategist at invesco is
that this is not the last tightening
cycle we need to be prepared for it to
be faster and for more substantial moves
to be made over the course of the year
relying less on ford guidance means that
you risk unhinging market expectations
about interest rates said vincent
reinhart former fed economist
who is now the chief economist at mellon
okay so what this means is that you
can't rely on what the fed is going to
do next which means uncertainty which
means people take money out of the
market when people are scared they take
money out of the market they start
investing in things like bonds right
they don't invest as much in stocks they
don't invest as much in mortgages they
just don't invest in as many things
you're about to see a tightening because
of the fed getting involved this way and
that was brought about by the insane
spending bridge embarked upon by both
parties but especially the democratic
party over the course of the last year
and then over the course of the last two
years
right during the pandemic there was this
idea that we could pay people to stay
home that might have been a decent idea
in the first couple of months
beyond that once we knew the data it
made no sense whatsoever we kept doing
it we blew trillions and trillions of
dollars into the economy there are
people who ended last year with more
assets than they had at the beginning of
the pandemic and they hadn't been back
to work
because we blew so much money into the
economy and now the fed is forced to
tighten interest rates and do so
unpredictably meanwhile the fed released
a separate one-page statement that
spelled out high-level principles to
guide a process for significantly
reducing its holdings the central bank
in 2020 cut short-term interest rates to
near zero and started buying bonds to
lower long-term rates as the coronavirus
pandemic hit the us economy triggering
financial market volatility in a deep
short recession
officials pledged to hold interest rates
near zero until inflation was forecast
to moderately exceed two percent pell
indicated that he and his colleagues
believe those goals have now been met
and so now they have to divest
themselves of the i believe something
like nine trillion dollars in assets
that are being held by the fed it's
something insane
okay all of this is uh is is bad news
for the immediate future of the economy
but it's pain that has to be gone
through because once you go on a
spending bit you wake up the next
morning with a hangover and that's
really where we are at this point okay
in just one second we'll get to the
continuing panic over covert that is
completely unjustified by the available
data first let's talk about keeping your
home safe i'm sure we all know about the
ring video doorbell i've talked about it
a thousand times but there is something
you may not know which is that ring also
makes an alarm it is true ring makes an
alarm ring alarm is an award-winning
home security system with available
professional monitoring best of all you
can easily install it yourself i did it
myself it's simple to set up it is easy
to use it's got all of the sensors from
motion doors windows that will work on
any house or apartment like yours i get
notified right on my phone whenever
anything is detected that's why i've
partnered with rings so like me with
ring alarm you and your loved ones can
rest easy knowing that ring is helping
to protect your home it's more than just
security you can add sensors that help
protect your home from flood freeze and
fire as well my favorite part
professional monitoring gives the
ultimate peace of mind it is part of a
ring protect subscription there are no
long-term commitments if anything
happens professional monitoring will
call you can request emergency services
on your behalf best of all rings
professional monitoring is an amazing
deal yet award-winning professional
monitoring for less money than most
professional alarm companies ring has an
award-winning alarm go to ring.com
forward slash ben to get a great deal on
a ring alarm home security kit today
that is ring.com forward slash ben go
check them out right now alrighty we'll
get some more in just one moment first
the latest episode of the adam corolla's
comedy series truth yeller is streaming
right now adam is joined by silicon
valley and deadpool actor tj miller tj
has some thoughts about basic health
considerations in a post-covered world
check it out
ladies and gentlemen comedian actor and
friend tj miller
[Applause]
oh my gosh hello
sorry i was i was just jogging i was
trying to find my dog
but i double fisted because you know it
evens out as you jog the weight this guy
looked at me and he goes it's true it is
true
i'm joking but you're serious this guy
really does
do it hi hey thank you for having me
thanks for coming out oh i'm excited
this is just a prop though do you want
this
oh you won't take it huh why coven you
one of those guys huh
well drink a stranger's beer because of
covid
so head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code miller for 25 off
your membership right now look out for
the new episode with tj miller right
this moment also it's never been easier
to listen to all of our content on the
go why because we've launched listen
this means you're able to listen to all
your favorite daily wear content on the
web and the dw app listen is here to
make soaking up our content as
convenient as possible with a limited ad
audio experience whether it's catching
morning wire with a morning cup of
coffee taking in the latest hot takes
from your favorite house or exploring
our growing radio theater you'll get all
the content you love and if you get
interrupted no worries you can pick up
right where you left off with continue
listening and that's not all we've made
sure it's available to members and
non-members so get ready to listen we've
got a lot to say you are listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile while the fed is basically
treating the pandemic as over i mean
that's really what's happening here the
fed is saying the pandemic is over we
need to stop with all this nonsense the
federal government refuses to do that so
you still have anthony fauci dodging on
what it would look like for the pandemic
to be over because again your
bureaucrats bureaucrats rely on
uncertainty because then they get to
provide the certainty in a world of
uncertainty that they have helped create
so they refuse to tell you you can live
a free life they will be dictating to
you whether you will be free or not free
and they will never offer you any sort
of timeline or actual metric to follow
this happens by the way all the time on
a personal level i mean it's crazy i
remember fairly recently i was dealing
with an organization where there were
some coveted rules that were being
applied at this organization and all we
kept asking for is when do the coveted
rules change we need actual metrics we
need actual dates and they kept saying
well we can't give that to you if we
give that to you you might hold us
accountable for it that's the anthony
fauci here is the second greatest of all
doctors after jill biden explaining that
there are really no metrics to determine
when the pandemic is over
where we want to be
is that sufficient control and control
we mean not eradication like we did with
smallpox that's unreasonable
not necessarily elimination
like we've done with polio and with
measles by mass vaccination campaigns
but a level of control
that does not disrupt us in society
okay well that that's not a metric i've
noticed that you're not giving a metric
by the way
americans are picking up on this
according to the associated press
early in the pandemic ryan wilson was
careful to take precautions wearing a
mask not really socializing doing more
of his shopping online the 38 year old
father and seafood butcher from
castleberry florida says he relaxed a
bit after getting vaccinated last year
he had a few friends over saw his
parents more still making sure to mask
up at places like the grocery store the
recent virus search hasn't caused him to
change his behavior much because he's
vast and has read that the variant
causes less of your illness and like
many wilson has come to believe covet 19
is probably never going fully away it'll
become endemic we'll be stuck with it
forever it's frustrating but what can
you do about it many americans agree
they're going to be stuck with it
forever at least for a long time a poll
from the ap shows that few just 15
percent say they will consider the
pandemic over only when code 19 is
largely eliminated by contrast 83
percent say they will feel the pandemic
is over when it's largely a mild illness
which by the way is correct however what
is not correct is how many americans
believe that it's not a mild illness the
poll shows 59 percent of americans think
it's essential they'd be personally
vaccinated against cover 19 to feel safe
participating in public activities okay
that is that is fair enough but
underscoring what authorities call
alarmingly low coveted 19 vaccination
rates in the united states children ages
5 to 11 just 37 of parents consider it
essential that their kids are vaccinated
before they return to normal which of
course is true
okay and only 47 percent of americans
think they need to get a booster 64 of
americans now say they're always or
often avoiding large groups 65 say they
are wearing face masks around others
both are up from 57 in december so this
is the part that's totally crazy the
reason it's crazy is because our public
health officials are saying stupid
garbage over and over and over to scare
people meanwhile denmark's like we're
done
according to newsweek denmark prime
minister matthew frederiksen announced
on february on january 26th that denmark
would be throwing out most coveted 19
pandemic restrictions including mass
mandates
restrictions currently in place are for
the public to wear masks on public
transportation in restaurants shops and
people entering healthcare facilities
and retirement homes however following
the february first change of
restrictions masks will only be required
in hospitals healthcare facilities and
homes for the elderly
frederick said frederickson said we say
goodbye to the restrictions and welcome
the life we knew before as of february
1st denmark will be open
according to the health minister magnus
hunichy denmark's recent cases have
covered were more than 46 000 daily on
average however only 40 people are in
icus
heineken says we can continue with
strong epidemic surveillance and we can
react quickly if necessary
he said there could be a rise in
infections and some people might need to
get boosted
but denmark is done
denmark is done and you're going to see
more and more countries being done but
the united states is going to be one of
the last countries to be done see one of
the great myths about the united states
is that the united states is highly
freedom oriented on issues like this no
half the united states is half the half
of the united states is more liberal
than the most liberal states in europe
half of the united states is to the left
of sweden and denmark like well to the
left of sweden and well well to the left
of denmark as well
all of this is based on bad data
it is i mean the reason it's based on
bad data by the way is because again a
huge number of americans have natural
immunity to this thing and we've just
ignored it all the way down okay final
note
i just have to comment on this because
it's hilarious so neil young who uh
apparently is some sort of singer
uh so he he had said to spotify that
unless they got rid of joe rogan they
should lose his music right his music
should go away so spotify was like okay
bye to the hollywood reporter we want
all the world's music and audio content
to be available to spotify users said a
spokesperson with that comes great
responsibility in balancing both safety
for listeners and freedom for creators
we have detailed content policies in
place we've removed over 20 000 podcast
episodes related to covet since the
start of the pandemic regret neil
young's decision to remove his music
from spotify but hope to welcome him
back soon
young had said on january 24th i am
doing this because spotify is spreading
fake information about vaccines
potentially causing death to those who
believe the disinformation spread by
them they can have rogan or young not
both
okay well basically as soon as neil
young said spotify you can have young or
everybody's like okay just buy like you
could literally have picked any other
name out of that you can have young or
carrot top and spotify's like well we
will catch you later you and your dozen
fans enjoy
i love that people keep running up
against the iceberg that is joe rogan's
show people on the left keep saying over
and over that they want to get rogan
booted and then it turns out that rogan
is making too much money for spotify
again the best revenge folks as always
is success no one cares about neil young
but joe rogan has 11 million listeners
to his podcast every episode alrighty we
will be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime
make sure to go check out the michael
knowles show that is available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feldt executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wiedowsky associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high events audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
a liberal supreme court justice steps
down the dhs secretary gets caught on
tape admitting that the situation at the
southern border is historically bad and
joe rogan survives another attempt by
the woke left to cancel him check it out
on the michael knowles show